on passe au quiz Nicolas sur quoi est-ce
que vous allez nous challenger ce soir
je vous propose un quiz ce soir sur les
salles obscures il y en a ils ont parlé
des cinémas dans les Yvelines alors des
salles actuels ou encore plus anciennes
vous allez voir on va remonter le temps
vous qui nous regardez sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez bien évidemment
jouer devant votre télévision ou votre
ordinateur et puis les invités bien
évidemment vous pouvez et bien répondre
aux questions allez
si comme on dit dans le cinéma et alors
on commence le quiz avec une question
globale sur les cinémas dans les
Yvelines à votre avis combien y a-t-il
de cinéma dans le département
[Musique]
200 environ
150 environ 150
une idée les invités peut-être 80
Gabriels
[Musique]
allez deuxième question nous prenons la
direction de plaisir les plus
précisément du centre commercial mon
grand plaisir c'est l'un des derniers
centres commerciaux à être sorti de
terre dans les Yvelines et il y a un
cinéma
UGC de neuf sales flambant neuf mais
quand est-ce que ce cinéma a ouvert ses
portes
2020 ou 2021
[Musique]
2022 c'était en mai 2021 et alors la
particularité en fait c'était que
l'ouverture a fait suite à une fermeture
de 6 mois de cinéma dans le contexte
vous savez de la de la crise sanitaire
allez troisième question on remonte le
temps cette fois-ci regardez ces images
de ce cinéma et à votre avis où se situe
ce cinéma
je dirais dans une des villes de 50 ans
en Yvelines
[Musique]
le 6 et 7
Élancourt
alors vous avez vu cette première image
elle date des années 90 et aujourd'hui
le cinéma ressemble plutôt à ce que vous
voyez à l'image voilà on est juste en
face du prisme à Élancourt deux
nouvelles images regardez bien ce
monsieur
et alors là c'est une question de
rapidité il est connu à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire qui c'est
alors c'est vrai que pour nos amis de
Triel un peu compliqué cette question
ça doit être le directeur d'un cinéma
mais alors lequel est-ce que vous avez
reconnu ce personnage ça fait des années
qu'il est à la tête de son cinéma du
ciné 7 justement
je sais plus son prénom
du ciné 7 d'Élancourt voilà
pour jouer plutôt
alors ensuite allez cinquième question
il existe plus aujourd'hui mais à
l'époque fin des années 90 début des
années 2000 ce cinéma avait beaucoup de
succès avec de longues files d'attentes
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire où se
déroule justement ces files d'attente
c'est un cinéma Gaumont qui a été
détruit ensuite et qui est situé pas
très équité si tu es pas très loin d'ici
j'en ai aucune idée
dans votre écran ça va peut-être vous
rappeler des souvenirs en tout cas moi
j'en ai un je vous le raconte juste
après c'est le cinéma de l'espace 50 ans
en fait avant le cinéma de Skywest comme
vous connaissez et bien il y avait ce
cinéma de l'espace Saint-Quentin fermé
en 2004 il était situé en face de la
médiathèque au niveau de l'actuel Burger
King et du restaurant crazy hall juste
en face de lactuelle médiathèque alors
petit souvenir moi j'ai vu Star Wars La
menace fantôme épisode 1 en 1999 dans ce
cinéma effectivement il y avait une file
d'attente comme ça ça remonte un peu
exactement c'est ça allez avant dernière
question oui le quiz est long
aujourd'hui désolé désolé mais je
profite de mon passage de l'un peut-être
de mes derniers passages avant mon grand
départ vous le savez grand départ pour
la Nouvelle-Zélande regardez cet extrait
de reportage réalisé en 2008
avec la fermeture du cinéma Jacques
Becker c'est une page de l'histoire de
qui se tourne classée Harry SS et de
salle avait été entièrement rénové en
2003 5 ans plus tard sa fermeture est
une certitude
alors est-ce que vous pouvez me dire où
se situe ce cinéma
Mathilde une idée les invités je pense
que c'est pas pour les a perdu parce que
là on est vraiment
je vais dire au pif
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce n'était pas
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'était un
plaisir et alors pour être précis il est
situé en fait sur l'actuel terrain
occupé par mon grand plaisir vous voyez
il y a des petits indices dans le cousin
faire attention à tout ce qu'on dit vous
voyez c'est situé sur l'actuel terrain
en fait de mon grand plaisir ça a changé
allez dernière question là je pense que
nos invités ils peuvent ils peuvent
répondre ils peuvent avoir la réponse
vous allez voir un extrait d'un
reportage réalisé en 2011 nous revenons
avec les acteurs sur le lieu du tournage
du côté d'Orphin regardez
ah ben là bien sûr bienvenue 50 ans
après nous avons retrouvé Petit Gibus
sur les lieux du tournage à Orphin
moment de Rambouillet
Martin Lartigue de son vrai nom garde un
bon souvenir de l'aventure une aventure
qui prenait très à cœur ah bah c'était
naturel mais on était dans l'histoire
quand c'était triste j'étais vraiment
triste je croyais que c'était la
terrible quoi là le traître quand on
doit le fouetter et que
on va le torturer moi on va vraiment le
tuer tout alors je fonds en larmes alors
à votre avis on parle de quel film je
crois que Frédéric padel la guerre des
boutons c'est ça on va voir la réponse
s'afficher tout de suite
on voit des images du film donc il
s'agit de la Guerre des boutons c'est un
film réalisé
la guerre des boutons
voilà la guerre des boutons films
réalisés par Yves Robert tourné en 1961
sortie en 1962 premier adaptation du
livre de Louis Pergaud publié en 1912
merci Nicolas dandry je crois que vous
aviez une question aussi pour nous sur
le cinéma est-ce que vous savez que dans
La menace fantôme il y a dark Maul
interprété
parc qui est un immense champion de kung
fu parce qu'en fait l'équipe de Lucas et
puis l'équipe de Star Wars cherchait
vraiment l'art qui correspondait au
gestuelles qu'on trouve dans la garde
des étoiles dès le début dès le sabre
laser et ils l'ont trouvé avec le
championne Chinois et les armes de
bouddhac Des Moines tahus de Houdeng
avec les épées de woodang et alors c'est
un hasard mais samedi soir vous aurez 3
minutes de démonstration avec la musique
de La menace fantôme et les sabres
lasers de Star Wars et vous allez voir
comment l'adéquation se fait entre les
deux entre la culture chinoise et les
Jedi la culture
au niveau du maniement des armes je
pense que
ça je pense
et bien je crois savoir qu'on reçoit la
troupe Déclic Théâtre vous savez c'est
spécialiste de l'improvisation et de
linoise ou c'est que il y a des
illustres star du cinéma et de du
stand-up français qui sont sortis de
cette école je pense que je vais aller
chercher dans les archives de Déclic
Théâtre pour essayer de vous préparer un
petit quiz moi si je vais essayer de me
préparer pour être un peu moins nul